good evening everybody I'm Andrea
shackling assistant director of on
campus programs in the office of alumni
relations I'm also a two-time alum so I
am personally very excited to welcome
you all to the first event in our new
young alumni story series show and tell
I want to thank Kristen from modcloth
you'll meet everybody I mentioned in a
moment for reaching out to us in making
tonight's stories possible and of course
i want to thank alan and day and evan
who you'll be hearing from we have one
more young alumni story this semester on
November eighteenth and two next
semester on februari 17th and March 31st
you can find all of the information
online at CMU edu slash alumni if you
enjoy yourselves tonight and you will
please tell your friends and spread the
word so join me now in welcoming your
alumni to tell us the story of modcloth
from dorm room to boardroom
hi everybody and thank you for coming my
name is Kristen gent and I am with
talent acquisition at modcloth and
tonight we're really excited to be part
of show-and-tell because we're we love
to tell stories and we love to be
interactive with our customers and so
tonight you're all going to be our
customers as we tell our story for those
of you who are not familiar with
modcloth we're an online clothing
boutique and we specialize in vintage
inspired indie fashion and we were
started at CMU by two students at the
time right here on campus they started
modcloth out of their dorm room and so
it's an amazing successful story that
we're really proud to be part of and
really proud to be tied to CMU to get a
better feel for the style of modcloth
we're going to start out with a little
video from one of our founders Susan and
two of our buyers as they're talking
about some of our some of our vintage
pieces that they had picked for the site
mom we just got done sourcing for our
next one of a kind vintage collection
Lindsay and ferry to of the fabulous
like hot fires and let's step into it so
this is one of my favorite items in the
collection I think it's pretty amazing
this dress from the sixties um so to
better explain the modcloth story I've
brought along three alum who all
happened to be part of our tech team
here in Pittsburgh Alan Lew who is our
vp of information systems j paulette who
is a senior software architect or as
he's known around the office our senior
geek and evan taylor who is acting p.m.
of business intelligence we also have a
former analytics intern with us who is
currently at CMU Jillian Sal way so
we're gonna start with Evan we're going
to start with Ellen we're going to start
with Alan so I didn't have much to share
about because i feel like i went to CMU
a really long time ago but graduated in
2001 and information systems was on the
special four and a half year track and
got my bachelor's so i definitely
encourage that I'm just kidding but
after graduating and information systems
I graduated right at the time of the
wonderful com bust and did medical
devices for a couple years at med rad
respironics and then jumped over to
retail so it's been some time and
american eagle launched Martinus and 77
kids which was a really fun projects
spent a little time and general
nutrition center of all these companies
are based in pittsburgh and then he got
recruited to modcloth so Jay
hi I'm Jay plot um I actually didn't do
an undergrad at CMU I did a mass tourism
information technology is a part-time
program so I had actually was working in
the area I started with a company called
h2 design group I moved over to IBM
downtown when it was part of trans arc
and then continue this part of IBM did
my Master's there while working
full-time and then after a couple years
of doing couple interesting projects
have moved on to my loss and I'm Evan
taller I'm actually a double CMU I did
my undergrad in mechanical engineering
and my masters and entertainment
technology while I was here I was the
president of CMU TV I did Red Team
Racing that's when we had a car drive
for the desert and race itself so after
I graduated I went to walt disney
studios home entertainment did a lot of
work in blu-ray got to play with the
lost guys how to start up in town for a
while called evil genius designs and
then went on to mod cloth so what we're
going to do is we're going to tell you
the mod cloth story in three different
ways the first way we're going to tell
you the story is the story of a
Pittsburgh and seeing you start up kind
of give you a little bit of the history
and they're going to go into some other
ways of telling the story and we think
if you see all three of them you'll get
a good handle on the way modcloth works
so for this first story I want to
introduce you to Eric and Susan this is
them now Eric and Susan again both
business students here at seeing you but
when they first met they looked a little
more like this and they were this is how
they look their senior year of high
school and their first year at CMU and
then the first instance of montcliff was
started in a dorm here at seeing you and
this is the desk and the logo notice the
word recycled it's a word we don't use
much anymore to describe the fashion so
here's the first website we've always
been an online company and we've always
existed under the guidance of Susan's
keen fashion sense so she always just
loved clothing shopping finding goodbyes
finding vintage things she wanted a way
to sell them online so
much of help from other folks seeing me
oh she made this first website and this
is how it was existed for about a year
in 2005 this is Winston he is our
corporate mascot and other official he
has many other official duties but he
came on the picture then and we've been
he's been happy to be with us ever since
in 2006 Eric and Susan got married and
you'll notice that we now have what
looks like a warehouse but that's
actually the basement of a house in East
they not friendship right so this was
our the first mod office mod mansion we
call it it's important to note that that
basement is not tall enough to stand up
in and that's pretty much the inventory
we had at the time of course centered
around shoes and dresses in 2008 we
moved the warehouse to Ambridge street
and the office to smallman street so the
office is still where it is in small
ministry in an old warehouse in the next
to lawrenceville and we started getting
enough inventory to need a whole team of
packers and shippers and you'll see it's
one of our employees lacy sitting on a
box of product there we actually had
enough to need boxes now we're just
exciting in 2009 we moved the warehouse
to carson street you'll see that box
around whole big warehouse at the point
there we occupy i think a third of that
now and we have over a hundred thousand
feet of just cool product that you can
even buy a mine it's awesome we're just
getting bigger and bigger in 2010 we
branched out and added two new offices
to our company so now we have a novice
in LA and an office in San Francisco of
course we're keeping the Pittsburgh
offices both the warehouse and the one
in small injury we need to define more
people more talent so we needed to go to
other places to find find these folks
and also we wanted to be closer to where
fashion was happening so of course
Pittsburgh's an awesome town but it's
not the most fashionable place so we
chose to go to LA for that
I've been here long enough I can say
that without getting punched I think and
that's where we are today so now the or
over 200 people and we just came off one
of the largest VC rounds that's venture
capital rounds in Pittsburgh histories
you'll see their 19.8 million dollars
and we got that to help us build our two
more are two other offices and we're
still growing today cool facts about us
now or with the second fastest growing
company in America according to inked
magazine and the number one growth in
retail and we're all over the place
we're all over internet most importantly
Perez hunted if you search on Google for
indie and clothing and mod and clothing
we always pop up that's us we're very
very well-known and we're growing
constantly and still on the upswing so
with all this growth I wanted to leave
this section with a little bit of an
interview of our employees so you can
understand what people think it's like
to work for my loss so it is a fun place
to work so the next part of is our story
you need a technology story of Nod floor
but aren't we just a retail company ma
clock is a retail as Evan mentioned
we've been just doing online sales since
we've our inception but we're trying to
go past that we're trying to do more
we're making online more social online
retail more social pushing the
boundaries of what we can do with
e-commerce and supply chain so try to
take the Mont cloth brand further doing
more than just making sales but also
making customers in building community
as I haven't mentioned we've been doing
a lot of growth this slide is actually
at a date we've doubled the amount of
space that we have moving from 2003 to
the present building out not just the
offices but also our in our warehouse
space and offices in new cities as well
one of the key things about modcloth is
connecting to customers Hmong class is
really a social experience it's a lot of
it's been word of mouth people talking
to help they're showing their friends
what they're getting it's not like huge
advertising campaigns it's a lot more
about people telling their friends about
what they found them what they like and
a lot of what we're trying to do is
encourage people to talk about modcloth
we do with things with Twitter we run
contests there we have our blog where
we've created a following all around the
mod lifestyle talking about things that
interest the culture the fashion we get
involved with Facebook a lot of Facebook
communities based around what we do and
we're also branching out to other ones
like colleague or chictopia side of our
blog Twitter today's I spy Thursday so I
think we missed the contests already but
every Thursday we do a contest of
looking for things on the site and then
doing prizes off of that our Facebook
community polyvore we do collaboration
with our customers helping them design
outfits using mod materials from a
technology standpoint under the hood we
use a lot of open source software we are
a big Ruby on Rails shop we try and use
a lot of different technology
virtualization out computing or major
platforms that were involved with we're
also getting into business analytics
trying to make sense of the numbers of
how are sales work how we move through
inventory trying to also push the
boundaries of configuration management
using chef to make our lives easier do
more with less
we're modcloth fits into the retail
space we tend to be down at the bottom
here so well a lot of companies
traditional retail they work from them
from a few sorcerer as a few suppliers
that all live up here in this little
triangle with mop sauce we try and go
further we want to go smaller into small
business owners mom and pop indie
designers do DIY designers small shops
who will bring their stuff forward for
the first time it's all behind the idea
of democratizing fashion and we'll talk
about this a little bit more but with
our programs like be the buyer modcloth
is doing is helping these smaller groups
designers companies get in touch with
the larger customer base and they
conditionally reach out to a lot of
these shops are one or two people who
are trying out designs sharing them with
the world they don't have the kind of
exposure that you get going into say one
of the major retailers so this is giving
them a chance to get a voice out there
let them understand what their customers
are looking for and get a feel for it
before they have to invest heavily and
make their to make their investments on
what they're going to actually produce
who do we need to make this work so
there is a large variety of help that we
need to make the sort of thing happen we
have people coming in designers computer
scientists information scientists
dustrial engineers user experience
business analysts math statistics it
takes a lot of different people a lot of
different backgrounds to make modcloth
work and as we've seen we are going
through some explosive growth so we are
trying to find
all the people we can help us take on
new challenges so speaking of challenges
what kind of challenges do we face
scaling a conversation doing word of
mouth is a core of what we do but as we
grow bigger and the brand goes bigger
how do you make that conversation still
work how do you keep connecting with
your customers in an organic way not
something that's forced or tired how do
you manage the risk of working with the
smallest vendors in the market mean a
lot of these companies like I said are
very small that's a lot of risk because
a lot of them haven't done this before
this is their first time through some of
these designers won't even make to the
next season how do you work with that in
a typical retail environment we launched
every six weeks so like you know they'll
see an entire season of stuff six weeks
they got a plenty of time to kind of
build campaigns take a launch from
exception purchasing it all the way
through to showing up on stores we have
25 launching 25 launches every day so we
just move at a much faster pace than
most retailers
so wanted to kind of describe you know
give you guys some stories on like why
modcloth is unique you know the other
day I was talking to customer service
and we have issues where sometimes we
get bad reviews right and if your Amazon
or Ebay what's a bad review I mean it
just helps you filter out the stuff you
don't want to sell anymore because
you've got tons and tons of product that
you know you know you know you have
plenty of choices but modcloth is a
little bit different because we've
already bought this stuff right and i
was talking to eric Cogar CEO is asking
him you know when we get a bad review
like you know how should we process that
what do we do with the bad review and
the comment was and this to give you a
little bit inside of how we view our
customer and I'll kind of lead with this
like we don't view our customer as
somebody who we buy we buy when we sell
it and you buy it and we want you to buy
as much as possible right that's kind of
the traditional retail model and that
fundamentally doesn't jive with us and
that's part of why we view all of our
customers as you're partnering with us
you know you're partnering with us
through the whole process of running a
company and so in this case of you know
what do we do with bad reviews you know
he's like well you know if I had to come
up with the right model you know if you
get a bad review what you do well you
know what we should do is we should see
if that's true so we should have a
customer care person go down to the
distribution center try on the product
and see if it's true look at the
stitching look at the quality you know
check the fit and see if what they said
is actually true because if it's true
and and the product is no good then we
shouldn't sell it I was like huh that's
not it you know that kind of makes sense
right we don't want to sell bad products
and we fundamentally don't want to put
our customers in a place that we're
making you or were enticing you to buy
product that you don't want I think
another great example is in our photo
you know studio and our photo person is
somebody who came from american eagle
and an american eagle and so I worked in
american eagle so I kind of know like
you know the way that we operate we make
the product look really good right I'm
you you tutting you tweak the color you
prop up you know like all the items so
that you get the best photography
possible you know you get the best
angles the best lighting and everything
is like perfect and it looks really good
but the challenge is you know
somebody opens up the box and they're
like that's not the color i bought
that's something completely different
and so there was a situation where there
was a dress and Eric and Susan were like
this dress doesn't look right and then
you know of course the photo guys like
what you mean you know I think it looks
great and Susan's comment was the bow
looks perfect and I know that when you
open the box the bow is not going to
look like that you know instead so you
know he's like well yeah I put a little
wire in there to stand up the bow and
you know pinned it back in the right
places so it stood perfectly and she's
like but that does it's not going to
show up like that so don't make it look
like that and so we've actually told our
you know our photo team make the product
look the way the product actually is
mind-blowing right i mean who does this
is this like you know this is how you
run a company but to us this is like
what makes us unique this what this is
what makes us a partner with our
customers not trying to you know entice
you give us all your money right that's
not the way that we saw the way that we
roll so talking more about kind of
community you know trends don't last
forever and the traditional model is
will design it will go check you know
what's the latest fashion in Paris
what's the latest fashion in New York
well you know will design it and then
we'll produce it and you buy it and
that's how you know most most apparel
companies work but for us it the
communities are what drive our company
the community is what decides what's the
next trends so with our with our company
in the way that we have our be the buyer
program where the community actually
acts like buyers for us those are all
ways that we include the community so
that we're not the one telling you what
to wear but our community is the one
that's driving like all stages of life
cycle you know these are just all the
different outlets that we use you know
and I want to highlight some of them
like crowdsourcing you know
crowdsourcing is where you guys as
customers and the rest of our customer
base gets to be part of how we source
our products you know social gaming is
another big component I mean we you know
gaming we want to be involved with
everything that we do because we're I
mean you know I don't know if you
remember in the video one of her
comments was what did you say I'm
totally blanking out
oh she was talking about a you know yeah
like they told me to have a colorful
resume and you know be really fun and
energetic I mean that's who we are as
modcloth I mean we we really love
engaging with people we really love
being down to earth you know and then
likewise you know gaming is fun so we
want gaming to be part of our website
experience we wanted to be part of how
you interact with modcloth and then you
know community social you know obviously
in the social realm that you know we
take a different approach where you know
the traditional retailer social what is
social all about like revenue like how
do we tap these markets you know to
increase revenue but for us social is a
way that we interact with our customers
you know our blog is nothing more than a
blog like we're not trying to sell
anything on our blog our blog is just
interacting with our customer talking
about a lifestyle and engaging with them
in our lifestyle and for example Fashion
Week you know in New York you know think
fashion week woohoo you know like we we
get invited Fashion Week not because we
sell clothes but because of our blog you
know our presence in the environment
like our presence like in the social
area is so exciting based on just what
we've right not because you know we're
the latest and greatest in fashion
check out what's there like we had a
whole week we're talking about use it
and let me gave away free songs right so
I cannot even imagine essa Sara Lee yeah
one of the interesting statistics is
like our conversion you know if you
think of a traditional retail conversion
you know can be anywhere from like 15 to
like you know two or three percent our
conversions really low and we're totally
okay with that you know we want people
to come to our website we want them to
engage with our brand and if you don't
to buy today that's totally fine with us
I mean conversion is not a number that
drives you know our organization this
distant slide is the blue bars represent
kind of this life cycle of product so
designing the design process you know
creating the sample buying the materials
you know producing it and then
reproducing it green is where we feel
like we as the retailer we can help the
customers be more involved with our
brand where you guys can be involved
with designing or even our products or
you know once we create samples that's
where we get feedback hey are these
samples the right samples are these the
things you want to buy once you know
once we have everything ready taking
pre-orders it's a functionality we just
recently launched where people can
actually start getting early access to
products but what that means it allows
us to make smarter decisions so that
we're buying the stuff that you guys
actually want and the other stuff we
just get off our site this just kind of
some of our crowdsourcing on the right
you see the visa and then all these
different things you know we really want
to engage more and more deeper with our
community so be the buyer exist today be
the writer exists but we won't be the
designer be the stylist be the model we
want all of those things to be how we
engage our communities and then on the
left is more of just the opportunity
right we're we're focused on one style
one brand right now but you know what
everyone has seen is like not just our
brand is unique but kind of our approach
to retail is unique and these are all
the different directions that we can
grow so next it's time for games yay M
prizes so we wanted to run a game with
you guys we want to run be the buyer so
you guys can all be buyers today and
experience what it's like and then
afterwards you can be so exciting to go
home and go to our website and Votto
more product so be the buyer I wanted to
walk you guys through what it actually
looks like so this is be the buyer page
so we present you with images of the
product we show you the price of what we
would probably sell it for which is
subject to change and then you can pick
it or skip it so basically do I like it
or do I not like it and we cycle through
products you know hopefully around like
10 a day of different products that come
through and then what happens is that
based on if if it gets picked you picked
it so then we start selling it online so
that's kind of to be the buyer program
so Evans going to run the game for us so
we need you to arrange yourselves into
10 groups so the tables didn't quite
line up properly so what we'll do is
we'll do on this side of the room these
double tables every row is going to be a
team you're not evenly matched people
wise but that's okay it'll all come out
in the wash and then on this side of the
room the back three or one team at the
front three and there's no one at the
first one will be another team everyone
got that does that make sense so you
guys every row as a team and a back
through your team and the front for your
team good okay okay
so imagine you're at Fashion Week and
imagine you're about to see a
presentation by a fantastic new designer
who's come up with you and says okay I
have dresses I have some accessories I
have some apartment items to sell on the
website but as modcloth we can't sell
them all we can only sell some of them
we can only buy two from each category
so the way this is going to work is
we're about to present you with some
products some of these were actually be
the buyer items on our site some of
these were products we selected and some
other some of these are products that
don't even exist yet you get a preview
so what you're going to do on the top of
your sheet right the names the folks in
your group so we can find you again
later because there are prizes and what
happens is when you see a group of
products the first you need to choose
three products that you want as a
consumer so hey I think this is cool
yeah I think I would wear this and then
next thing you're going to do is choose
two products that you should buy and the
way the game is going to work is at the
end of this rounds we're gonna collect
the sheets Adam up and the group that
can guess the trends in the room the
best will win so your influence affects
the entire room so you not only have to
guess what you think the folks near you
would want you have to guess what
everybody would want and that's the hard
part about doing this been real because
we think we know it's cool but we're
never as serves our consumers so you
guys know the best of what's actually
cool and that's how we do to be the
buyer program to help us with these are
decisions and like Alan said make sure
that we provide you with the coolest
thing possible see you guys ready
everyone
maybe oh all right it's a get closer
everyone can we get close all right here
we go so first we'll start with dresses
dresses are modcloth staple products we
are best known for our unique and cool
dresses so you'll see we have six
dresses so on your sheets write down
three that you want and to you think you
would buy we'll leave it up for about a
minute
Oh
alright guys about 30 seconds left
alright see so you can keep discussing
amongst yourselves but we'll move on to
the next round so that was dresses the
next category we're going to move into
his accessories so in this round of
accessories we have a Star Trek wallet
handbags earrings a belt a necklace and
a hats now the hard part about
accessories is they're not necessarily
I'm sorry is this better excellent so in
this round of accessories we have a Star
Trek wallets a handbag earrings belts
necklace and hat so the same rules apply
pick three products that you think you
might want and to you think we should
sell on our website
about 30 seconds left
all right that was the Accessories
category and now our final be the buyer
category apartment items this is my
personal favorite category item number
one a bear head bottle opener item
number to a bird bottle holder item
three is a both salt and pepper shakers
item four is actually a lamp so that you
put the light bulb at the top there
above the birds item 5 is a math and
they're at a clock I don't know if you
can read the numbers but six times two
is the top there's square roots of 442
and then item number six is a bento box
lunch pail and again pick three items
that you would like to own and to you
think we should sell on the sites
30 seconds left all right now i have to
remind everyone one last time to make
sure that your names are on the paper or
else we can't find you and give you
prizes so again everyone's names are on
your paper all right so we're gonna go
around and collect the votes and in the
meantime we're going to show you a
another quick video and this one we have
our products we have mod models and we
go on theme fashion shoots a lot of the
times to help show off outfits and cool
events so we're still counting up the
votes but we're going to start our
second game so the other type of thing
we mentioned before was the be the
program so you just participated in be
the buyer and now we're going to try
what we call name it and win it or be
the writer so we've had a few of these
contests before on our website and the
way it works is we asked our fans again
to contribute either a name or a
description or both to our products to
help explain it to help sell it to think
how they would use the product in the
world so a few products we've actually
done this list for real so far you'll
see the forget to me dot frock to be
careful when I say that Lacey Breaky
Heart and a chloral line so these we did
this summer asking of course for summer
themed nautical themed contributions and
we've ass also asked in the past for
descriptions so this one has been
written by our fans and you'll see
people are at a very distorted dress
kind of to help you think of what you
might do with it how they were inspired
by it so for this game it'd be too easy
if we just let you come up with a name
or description for a product so the way
this game is going to work and
especially how the writing team works
here at modcloth there's awesome there's
often a theme that we have to attribute
to address so maybe it's seasonal maybe
it's summer winter maybe it's about a
type of event that's going on maybe it's
about a game or sport that might be
happening so the way this is going to
work in the same teams we're going to
give you a noun and a verb that you must
use so the noun must be used in your
product name and your verb must be using
your product description you may have
noticed that there are products on
easels around the room if you can't see
them I'll go through them all very fast
on screen and what's going to happen is
there's going to be two groups competing
to name a product and describe it you'll
have three minutes to come up with your
name and description
and then you'll have to present it to
the groupie love 30 seconds and tell the
story and get us and sell us really on
your product and again our fans are the
best judge of what's cool or not so then
everyone in the room will have to decide
which of these best exemplifies the
product and again there are prizes so
mystery dress number one mystery dress
number two mystery dress number three
mystery dress number four and mystery
dress number five so it's going to be
your and mr. just number six it's going
to be your guys job to help help us
described and named these products so
we're going to bring the easels to you
and you'll be competing in groups so Row
1 versus row to row 3 versus row 4 row 5
verses row 6 the background against the
back row over there and then the first
half over here in the first half over
here in the same groups you're in before
so bring will bring the dresses out to
you and then we'll in our lovely hats
you'll choose your noun in your verb at
random and we'll see how this goes
putting up on screen oh you're gonna
have to raise the mic like a great deal
for here good evening everyone our verb
and noun for the day is fashion and
shine so I present to you this Spring
Fashion Fling you can't have flowers
without sunshine and this dress will
have you shining through spring summer
and even fall blossoms of color are
scattered over a full skirt and a sweet
bow completes the look I hope you enjoy
it team number two
so they're going to be describing the
same dress we had summer and and read
which was tough but it's funny because
they came up the spring which was
perfect in a segue daughter so our name
was summer bloom and Jason's going to
read the description and for our
description of our lovely dress imagine
yourself in this reading under the shade
of magnolia tree in full summer bloom
dress and the season one in the same
alright so now we're doing a cheer so
we're going to i'm going to say team one
and then you cheer if you like team one
and i'm going to say team two and then
you cheer if you're like team to and
evan will tell us who is the winner all
right you can absolutely cheer for your
own team all right ready team one team
two Evan Oh team two yay alrighty three
alright cydia the noun that we got was
winter and the worm that we had was love
so the name we've come up for a dress is
a spring after the long winter and
description hey everybody okay so the
story the perfect for out a spring
garden party you would want the tiny bow
and the perfectly shaped cricket past
year but with opaque forest green tights
and a pair pants
hi I'm Cassie so our verb was rest and
are now knows wardrobe we name the
dressing and talk at night after you
rest all day on the Cape slip into this
upscale floral pattern to go places with
your Gatsby crowd alright so I'll
announce team three and then team for
ready team three team four all right so
let's have team five and six come up at
the same time
alright so our noun was boy and our verb
was eat quite the combination but will
tell a little bit of a story about what
we were thinking when we saw this but
our name has come and get it boys and
instead of we don't really write down
any very description but we did think
out loud about a story and what we were
thinking about was you know our friend
his mother next door was attractive we
had a crush on her and she was very
wholesome but you know kind of boring
and she bakes you a pie or cake and then
she comes to you know the door or the or
the window and it lets it cool and so
you know come and get it boys eat your
heart out was how we kind of
alright that's a tough act to follow our
now must page and our verb was cook and
we decided the collar dress turn the
page tired of being the same person
every day turn the page and spice it up
cook up a new look in this phone and
solve them the sweetheart cut halter
dress is sure to bring heat to the
kitchen alright so ready team five and
team six teen 6 it is all right team
seven just team seven have a competitor
ok yeah why don't you guys come up
ok so our verb was enjoy and are now
with spring so put on this dress and
enjoy the trip of life in a whole new
way when your friends ask you why you're
so happy tell them it's a dress I am
humbled to present to you springtime hi
alright so are now is fall and our
verbiage run and so what we were
inspired by the first of all of the blue
colors of the vivid blue colors but also
the flowing nature of the collar so we
call this falling water frock alicious
and so just imagine yourself wearing
this dress around town as you run you
complete errands you meet friends and
your free flowing just like the
Monongahela River
so I totally lost track of the team so
I'll just say the first team and second
team all right so first team and
second-team second team it is all right
next two teams from the back forward I
guess is last two teams last two teams
so our noun was pug and our verb was
imagined so we named this dress curvy
the love Pug walking your dog doesn't
have to be a chore it's just another
excuse to get dressed up throw on this
frilly yellow frock and use that pooper
scooper with style and now imagine okay
so we named this mr. write me a poem
roses are red violets are blue yellow is
the poem waiting to be written for you
don this baroque inspired party dress
and any gathering stop searching for
your mr. right and just relax with this
cute flirty ensemble watch the power of
the pen network in your favor alright so
the first team and the second team
alright so next we going to do announce
the winners from the other game that we
play be the buyer so i'm going to show
you guys the images and then tell you
which which items were picked so from
the dresses the items that were picked
were number dress number two dress
number three and dress number 5 from the
accessories it's number three the
earrings number five the necklace and
number six the Hat no star trek wallet
yeah yeah I know and from the apartment
items it's the dachshund salt and pepper
shakers the lamp and the clock of course
so the winning teams so yeah the winning
teams come up so when I announced your
your names you guys can come up and
claim your prizes so there's a tie so
there's two winning teams it's a joe
woody Venky Prakash and tie
and the other winning team which wrote
all their last names is thanka erica
lauren Ruthie Stephanie rich Lori sue
tsukada Emily and Joe so so once these
guys clear out then we'll let the
winning teams from to be the writer also
coming yet prizes so how about at this
point if you guys have any mail so we
can use this opportunity to maybe take
some questions if you guys have any
questions you know and we can redirect
them to anyone any of the people that
are here but are there any questions our
products so the question is where are
the products manufactured so we both
have domestic and import products we
don't actually because we have so many
vendors we order from over 2,000
different vendors so actually the
products come in from all over the place
some Europe some Asia's but we are we
also because we order so much from LA
there's actually a lot of domestic
vendors there so we and we definitely
encourage that for sustainability I'm
sorry
yes yeah the actual manufacturing
happens in Los Angeles for a lot of the
products there's a really neat market
there in LA called san pedro mar 12 all
wholesale buying and a lot of the
manufacturing happens right outside of
that market next question it's
interesting actually I think about this
a lot and it's really hard to identify
our competitors Kristin trying to talk
here so yeah it's actually very
difficult to nail down our competitors
because not a lot of people have this
crowd sourcing model probably the most
popular is threadless but that's
t-shirts and not really in the dresses
category if you had to say by style some
of our main competitors are probably
Lulu's and Urban Outfitters but also i
mean but there's a distinct differences
in the way that we run our businesses
but i mean but it's a great question and
I mean I'm sure there's going to be a
lot of copycats also do you know it's
really in the last like two years that
our growth has taken off so what we're
definitely attracting more attention
especially with all the press so some of
that we send back to the vendor if
there's quality defects in the actual
yeah so we have a we very rarely run
sales so we're not a sale organization
you know we've definitely trained people
behind the fact that there's there's a
limited number of products so there's a
scarcity model so when we when we put up
an item sometimes it sells out even in a
few hours because people know that if
it's good and you want it you get it now
we run sales probably like twice a year
and those products those a lot of our
products sell very quickly i mean our
sale in the fur you know people said
that they added ibis of their cart and
by the time they got to check out you
know they obviously weren't able to
check out because they have so many
items that were already out of inventory
so we do have those two sales but then
also we have damages sales which is just
a you know not really necessary damage
but is all employee purchases so as
employees we get to go in and take that
and then the remaining product actually
goes to donation
absolutely I mean that's a big concern
of ours and we were fiercely fighting to
retain our culture you know in our San
Francisco office there's some weeks
where over ten percent of the office is
starting on in one day and you know
that's kind of happen iteratively right
you know because depending on the number
of people we have so it's very difficult
actually to retain our culture so we
have you know documentation we have you
know continual like training actually
around our culture so that we can
continue to propagate that but it is
challenging I mean we're definitely
going through a lot of growth pains with
two offices opening this year and you
know I think at the beginning of this
year we're about a hundred and thirty
employees and you know now we're not
even end of year and we've already on
board at 70 so it's challenging
do we provide them assistance so we so
sorry i haven't been repeating the
question that's really bad at me so the
question is like you know how we do we
provide assistance to our manufacturers
a lot of the manufacturers because
they're very small shops some of them
came and produce without us paying
upfront so a lot of them actually
requires to pay upfront which is very
untraditional in the retail in apparel
industry but that's one of the things
that we have to do because we go after
so many small like like indie designers
um it varies it's incredibly broad I'll
talk about our main category which is
our dresses they range anywhere from 30
to several hundred five hundred dollars
and that's the price point
mmm so the question is brick and mortar
if that's something that we've
considered it's not really a strategy of
ours you know a lot of what we do is
bringing that boutique experience online
and we don't really want to compete with
the boutiques because it boutiques are
you know it's a precious opportunity for
people to still go in like vent you know
vintage shop in or boutique shop so it's
not really a market that we're looking
to compete in and hasn't really been a
strategy for us so that is a great
question do we have a men's line so if
you notice if you go to our site we
actually have a men's category that's
just started this year but it's really
only in the context of gifting you know
a lot of our company is just we're
dealing with such rapid growth it's all
about what we can sustain with that
rapid growth we're the only thing that's
holding back a men's line is a men's
buyer so we've you want to volunteer so
we have a you know Susan who's really
the visionary behind modcloth in the
women's fashion we don't have that on
the men's side yet and that's really
what we're looking for demographic is
really difficult to nail down so you
know a lot of traditional apparel you
know you create your profile right and
that's your profile that you've got you
know that you've got that you carry
through and you know it's funny when i
worked at american eagle it really
weirded me out because the profiles were
katie and brandon you know and then
they've got these pictures in the office
of like all these pictures of all these
women you know and they're like that's
Katie I'm like cool it there's like 20
people up there but it's you know all
trying to capture that persona right
modcloth we don't have that because we
we cover such a broad spectrum of style
you know from everything from like emo
to retro to indy to vintage so all those
things are really difficult to capture I
mean are buying ranges anywhere between
i'd say like 15 to 35 but that's really
not I mean that's such a broad spectrum
of women and so it is difficult for us
to profile but we intentionally don't
profile because that would actually
limit the type of products that we buy
yeah that's a great question so what's
our average order by I would say you
know it there's obviously a huge
variance but in the beginning of the
year you know our average buys would be
like 70 pieces per unit upper product
and then you know right now going into
holiday you know we're trending anywhere
around like 300-400 be the buyers even
more because it's already been voted in
so those be the buyer items can be
anywhere for like 500 600 it's
interesting because you know we want to
always retain that scarcity model but
how do you retain a scarcely model when
you're trying to buy to demand and
demand is always increasing so it is a
challenging it's a challenging framework
that we're trying to we're still
navigating you know we have some pretty
advanced statistical models that we use
to try to predict our byes and and so
we're trying to solve it in different
ways but yeah it's a great question
so you probably need to ask someone
who's closer to our demographic than I
am
there's a there's one jacket our
Twilight jacket so yeah it looks like
you know the jacket that Bella where's
in Twilight is extremely popular and
it's actually a product that we've
stocked for several over a year right
other questions so what we have is our
buying team they're not necessarily
spread out but they're both they're
based in both LA in Pittsburgh and San
Francisco so between our three offices
we have different buyers what they do is
they scour different like vendors who
you know send catalogs or have websites
we go to a lot of trade shows there's
some really popular areas where there's
a concentration of wholesale fashion and
you know the LA district that I
mentioned earlier is a big one where
there's almost like you know a thousand
different small mom-and-pop type
wholesale apparel retailers that are in
this tiny little market and we'll go in
and you know our buyers will go in there
they may order one product they may
order you know like 25 products from one
one vendor so so our buying team is a
small team right now so it's not we're
not really you know have people but the
challenges we have a certain style that
we're trying to you know continue to go
down that line that it's actually very
difficult to find people that can really
you know hit that hit that style on
point and so that's one of the
challenges I mean it's actually it's
it's not it's not so broad in terms of
the style that we're trying to buy yes
yes
the I'm sorry oh absolutely yeah
absolutely the question is does the new
york fashion market have an influence on
us in absolutely i mean we so to kind of
tie on into the previous question you
know we do a lot of buying in europe as
well so we go to Paris and we go to
London and we do find there as well but
that's not the majority of our products
but we buy of New York our vendors are
scattered all over the US so yeah but
New York is a New York and LA are the
two biggest influences yeah so excluding
obviously Evan Jay myself you know a lot
of our modcloth employees are consumers
you know and it's it's really awesome I
mean you go to the office and I
definitely you know you guys are welcome
to talk to Kristen about visiting the
office but it's really cool I mean a lot
of the you know a lot of our people the
people that work at modcloth our
consumers of the brand so you go into
the office and like they themselves are
so passionate and so you know like
excited about the brand I mean they get
a sixty-three percent discount if you
work at modcloth so I mean that's you
know that's significant
advantages or disadvantages yeah that's
a great question Pittsburgh is an
interesting market because you know a
lot of startup companies either start
here and move out or they just don't
start here you know if you go to like
this work tech council which is a big
you know community of companies you'll
notice very few that are in the retail
space in a lot of medical a lot of you
know in like industrial type like
organizations so it's a it is a
challenging place to start a business
but at once unique about Pittsburgh as a
market being like a smaller market than
say San Francisco is that we feel like
we're the best game in town so so it's
actually really easy to attract talent I
mean I feel like you're even the team
that we have up here is like some of the
best and brightest you know people that
we can get in Pittsburgh and so it's
actually easy to be awesome in
Pittsburgh and we like being awesome so
yeah so the question is do we want to do
our own in-house design absolutely not
so we are definitely our model is
allowing designers working with
designers and then the hope is actually
working with customers or desires so you
know be the designer is a program that
we want to get to where it's kind of
like the mix between Etsy and you know
large-scale retail where we can go
designers can present to us and then we
help bring their their design to market
so through voting and through even
having our own connections for
manufacturing you know we thought we've
talked about different models where we
can you know aggregate designs and then
push those out to manufacturing you know
in shop those shows out to different
manufacturing opportunities so yeah we
definitely don't want to get into
business of doing our own design because
if we feel like that would stifle our
creativity in terms of the options that
we have that's a that's a really
interesting question we've never gotten
to the case where I feel like we've
rejected a designer but the other
challenge is that the places that we go
to buy like the really large scale
designers have probably aren't there so
the LA market and then the trade shows
that we go to all the big designers once
you become big you actually focus on
just the people that are buying from you
so if you're big and Macy's and you know
and you do a lot of business Macy's
you'll probably stop going to the shows
because you know there's no reason for
you to be at this trade show trying to
drum up more business you know when
you've already you know tapped out your
you know your opportunity with you know
one of the large apparel retailers all
right well thanks everyone will be in
here to answer questions oh wait oh oh
yeah yeah so if you did it oh there's
another run of prizes oh yeah so if you
won so at this point we'll just make it
so everybody wins
so feel free to come up thanks guys